[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا في كل مكان اهلا بكم جميعا الى
حلقه جديده من برنامج من واشنطن في اول
يوم من ايام رمضان المبارك هذه الحلقه
تاتيكم من ميدان الحريه الواقع في وسط
العاصمه الامريكيه بين الكونجرس والبيت
الابيض سنخصص هذه الحلقه للسجالات
الامريكيه الساخنه حاليا بشان الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب
يدان في نيويورك ام لا سيكون معي خلال هذه
الحلقه حتى نهايتها كل من كمال نعواش
محامي معتمد لدى المحكمه العليا الامريكيه
وناشط في الحزب الجمهوري سيكون معي كذلك
رائد جرار مسؤول العلاقات الحكوميه في
منظمه الديمقراطيه الان للعالم العربي
مره اخرى يجد الرئيس السابق نفسه في مياه
قضائيه ساخنه وتجد معه البلاد نفسها بين
مخالب انقسام يبدو بلا نهايه
دعوه هذه الفئه القليله من معارضي الرئيس
السابق في نيويورك لمحاكمته لعده تهم تدخل
ضمن الجدل المستعر في البلاد حول ما اذا
كان يجب ان يحاكم ترامب ام لا فيما اصبح
يعرف بقضيه النجمه الاباحيه ستورميدانيز
وتشابك تلك القضيه مع ملف الانتخابات
الرئاسيه التي فاز فيها دونالد ترامب عام
وبينما ينفي ترامب انه كان قد التقى
دانييلز في اي وقت من الاوقات يتهم بانه
كلف محاميه انذاك بدفع مبلغ 130 الف دولار
اليها مقابل العدول عن كشفها عما تصفه
بعلاقه جنسيه اقامها
وبتسجيل ذلك المبلغ في سجلات مؤسسه
على انه كان لتغطيه نفقات قانونيه وهنا
مربط الفرس بالنسبه للمدعي العام في
نيويورك الذي يرى فيما قام به
ضلوعا في التخفي على طبيعه المبلغ المدفوع
مقربه من مكتب مدعي عام نيويورك
الذي يحقق فيه القضيه تجمعت فئه اخرى هذه
المره من مؤيدي
للتنديد بتحقيق ابراج وصفه التحقيق
بالمسير وكانت ترامب قد اعلن انه سيعتقل
يوم الثلاثاء الماضي وهو ما لم يقع ودعا
انصاره للاحتجاج
بشبارا السكريتير التنفيذي لمنظمه تسمي
نفسها نادي الشباب نيويورك الجمهوريه
نحن هنا لاستعاده الشارع نحتاج من المدعي
العام ان يركز على وظيفته وليس على تجييش
مكتب الادعاء من اجل اقامه دعاوى مسيسه
ليس مرغوبا ولا مصرحا بها نحتاج من المدعي
العام البنبراج ان يعود الى القيام
بوظيفته ويكف عن ملاحقه دونالد ترامب دون
وجه حق
على هامش هذه الاحتجاجات المحدوده جدا
لانصار دونالد ترامب في نيويورك تحدث كذلك
السكرتيره التنفيذي للنادي كافين واكس
بصراحه هذه الاتهامات تقوم على نظريه
قانونيه مستحدثه وتستند على نسق معين من
الحقائق اذا نظرت الى الامر دون تاويل كما
ان فتره التقاضي القانونيه انتهت واعتقد
انهم يدعون ان ترامب استخدم اموال الحمله
الانتخابيه لحل خلاف خاص على ايه حال هذا
امر لم يرد المدعون الفيدراليون الاقتراب
منه وكذلك المدعي السابق لمنطقه منهات
والان وبعد كل هذه السنوات يعودون لاحياء
هذه القضيه قبيل الانتخابات التمهيديه
بينما تظهر الاستطلاعات تقدم ترامب مقارنه
ببايدن
المدعي العام الفنبراج واجه مازق في قضيه
دانيلز فلو تجاهله فانه كان سيتهم
بالتخاذل في القيام بواجبه خوفا على
استقرار البلاد من توجيه التهمه ولكن الان
وهو يستعد ربما للاعلان عن قراره فانه
يواجه تهم بتسييس القضيه خاصه وانه
ديمقراطي وبذلك يتهم كذلك بانه قد يقوض
استقرار البلاد
براج حسب امره واكد ان واجبه هو النظر في
اتهامات خرق القانون الامريكي مهما على
شان المتهم بذلك اي في هذه الحاله الرئيس
السابق
واذا كانت اصداء القضيه محدوده حتى الان
في الشارع
فان ازرعها اكثر صخب في الكونجرس بين
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين
نحن نعيش في امريكا وينبغي ان تكون هناك
مساواه امام العداله الامر يتعلق باموال
شخصيه ولم يحاول ترامب اخفاءه كما ان سبع
سنوات مضت وهناك قيود قانونيه على المده
المسموح خلالها بالتقاضي واعتقد انكم
تعرفون ان هذا الامر مسيس واعتقد ان بقيه
البلاد تظن ذلك وقد تعبنا من هذا كله
هذه قضيه اخرى يحاول دونالد ترامب من
خلالها الدفعه بمصالحه وليس بمصالح الامه
فلنكن واضحين حيال ما يحدث هنا لا احد فوق
القانون حتى رؤساء مركز السابقين واذا تم
التحقيق ينبغي السماح باجراء تحقيق بشكل
سليم واذا حان وقت الاذان فليكن هكذا يعمل
النظام القضائي لا يوجد سبب للاحتجاج
ينبغي ان ياخذ القانون مجراه دون خوف من
احد او مجامله لاحد
برحب مجددا بضيفي في هذه الحلقه كمال
نعواش محامي وخبير قانوني معتمد لدى
المحكمه العليا الامريكيه وناشط في الحزب
الجمهوري ورائد جرار مسؤول العلاقات
الحكوميه في منظمه الديمقراطيه الان
للعالم العربي قبل ان ابدا النقاش معكم لو
سمحتم لي اريد ان ابدا بمراسله الجزيره في
الكونغرس بيسان ابو كويك بيسان بدايه ما
حجم المشكله التي يواجهها الجمهوريون في
الكونغرس في الدفاع الرئيس كما هو معروف
حكم برلمانيا مرتين ويتهم الان ليس بعلاقه
جنسيه مع نجم اباحيه بل بالضلوع في تزوير
حقائق ماليه وبنتهاك قانون الانتخابات عبد
الرحيم المشكله بالنسبه للجمهوريين هي
ربما تلقي الضوء على ذلك الانقسام في
صفوفهم وعوده ترامب ليتصدر العناوين راينا
التجمع الذي
طبعا الى الدفاع عنه على راسه كافه مكارثي
رئيس مجلس النواب الذي اعتبر بان هذا
التحقيق في هذه القضيه واحتمال توجيهتهم
بانه ليس الا دليل اخر على تاسيس القضاء
ومن ثم وجه تلك اللجنه الخاصه التي شكلت
مع استلام الجمهوريين لمجلس النواب
ويقودها مناصر ترامب النائب جيم جوردن وهي
لجنه تسييس الحكومه
لاتخاذ خطوات ومنها تم استدعاء
المحقق في المدعي العام في هذه القضيه
الفن دراك في منهاتن طبعا هذا هذه الاصوات
هي اصوات مرتفعه جدا هنا في الكونجرس تتهم
الاداره يعني ربما الديمقراطيين والقضاء
الامريكي بانه مسيس ويساء استخدامه ولكن
هناك ايضا اصوات اخرى جمه صامته في مجلس
الشيوخ لم نسمع الكثير من الجمهوريين
الذين
تحدثوا بصوت مرتفع دفاعا عن ترامب حاولوا
يعني ربما انتظار ماء سينجم عنه هذه
التحقيقات وان كان بالفعل ستواجه تهم ربما
قضيه بالنظر الى قضايا اخرى عبد الرحيم
مفتوحه الان وتحقيقات اخرى ان كان في
وزاره العدل المتعلقه بقضيه الوثائق
السريه او الهجوم على السادس من يناير او
قضيه محاوله الضغط على مسؤولين انتخابيين
في جورج وهي قضيه متفاعله نعبر عن
المقاطعه بيسان بيسان معذره على المقاطعه
الوقت يداهمنا
بالنسبه للجانب الجمهور الديمقراطي الان
يعني ما حجم المشكله التي يواجهها
الديمقراطيون في الكونجرس في ظل ما يقال
عن ان رؤساء ومسؤولين امريكيين سابقين
اخلوا بالقانون وبالاخلاق
مثلا جورج بوش في قضيه غزو العراق بتهم
كاذبه باختصار لو تكرمت عبد الرحيم يعني
هذه الجوانب لا تطرح هنا في السجالات في
الكونجرس خصوصا فيما يتعلق بكلينتون
ولوينس كيف تلك القضايا ومنها الذي ذهب
الى القضاء تم تسويته بشكل ربما
توافقي ما بين كلينتن والمدعي الذي كان قد
استدعاه على خلفيه كذبه في ادعاء قضائي
وقضيه مثلا التي تم ايضا تسويتها وصلت الى
المحكمه العليا ولكن بالنسبه للديمقراطيين
قضيتهم الان هناك من يتهم الجمهوريين
بانهم يسيئون استخدام سلطاتهم بمحاوله
التاثير على تحقيق جنائي وعلى القضاء من
خلال ما يقوم به
الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب من تحقيقات
الان في قضيه في هذه القضيه تحديدا ولكن
هناك ايضا في مجلس الشيوخ من التزم الصمت
لانهم لا يريدون ان يبدوا وبانهم يشجعون
القضاء على توجيه تهم الى ترامب ويزيدون
من هذه التهم الموجهه للديمقراطيين بانهم
ربما متواطؤون مع القضاء في استهداف
ترامبو ملاحقته
بيسان شكرا جزيلا ومعذره على مقاطعتك
السيف الوقت بطبيعه الحال يداهمنا في كل
مره بسنه الجزيره في الكونجرس اعود الان
الى ضيفي هنا في ساحه الحريه ابداء
السيد كمال نعواش يعني ما طبيعه القرار
الذي تتوقع انت انه سيصدر عن الفن براك في
هذه القضيه هذه ما حدا بيعرف بس على حسب
اللي بنسمعه في الاخبار يعني لو خلينا
ناخذ اسوا اشي ممكن يصير انه يرفعوا دعوه
جنائيه ضده العقاب لها بسيط كثير هذه حتى
ما بتكون بسموها اشي مستمينه يعني اشياء
اكثرها
وهذا الشيء اللي بخلي كثير ناس يحكوا ان
هذه مسيسه
يوم بكون واحد رئيس في السابق اذا عمل اشي
غلط السلطه اللي الناس السلطه الحكوميه
اللي بتفتش على هذا الاشي عتم بتكون
السلطه الفيدراليه
العام الفيدرالي زي العماره اللي ورانا
هذه نادر واتطلعت هلا اخر مئه سنه اشوف
اذا عمره صارت وين مدعي عام تبع مدينه
يبحث عن رئيس عمرها ما صارت وهذا اللي
بيخلي الناس تحكي هذه مسيسه يعني
عطفا عليه رائد يعني ما حجم المشكله التي
تعتقد الان ان الامريكيين ممن يهتمون بهذه
القضايا بطبيعه الحال يواجهونها في ظل هذا
السجال بينما هو سياسي وما هو قانوني في
قضيه درامبو
هي القضيه معقده بالتاكيد هناك
قطمه بين السياسه والقانون انا من وجهه
نظري يجب ان تقوم السلطات القضائيه في
محاكمه اي شخص امريكي سواء كان رئيس او
غير رئيس اذا قام ذا هذا الشخص بانتهاك
القانون الامريكي يعني بدلا من المطالبه
بعدم محاكمه علينا المطالبه بمحاكمه كل
الرؤساء السابقين اللي ارتكبوا جرائم يعني
الدعوات السياسيه
عدم
حمل محمل المسؤوليه لانه كان رئيس هي
دعوات غير جيده غير غير ليست لها مصداقيه
يعني انا اؤيد
التحليل بان هناك بالتاكيد
يعني معامله مختلفه مقارنه بالرسائل
الاخرين بس بدلا من مطالبه السلطات
الامريكيه باعطاء ترامب المعامله التي
اعطيناها للرؤساء الاخرين ممن لم نحم
مسئوليه اخطائهم علينا ان نستخدم ما يحصل
مع الان كمبادره
للمطالبه السلطات الامريكيه
بالبحث عن جرائم اخرى ارتكبها ثلاثاء
اخرين وحملهم مسؤوليه كمان يعني انت رجل
قانون والقانون يقوم في العديد من حالاته
على القياس يعني قياس حاله في الوقت
الراهن بحالات سابقه في الماضي انما هل
يعفي ذلك من ادانه دونالد ترامب اذا ثبت
انه ارتكب جرم جنائي هل يعفيه من ذلك ان
رؤساء سابقين لم يحاكموا
هي من ناحيه كان لا لا يعفي لا يعفي عليه
بس احنا بنحكي عن قضيه عن قضيه مشبوه فيها
عن بحث عنه مشبوه فيه خليني افسر لك
بالضبط شو هم ليش الناس شاكين بالامر ان
السياسي هم بحكوا انه مزبوط صار عنده
علاقه جنسيه مع هذه المراه هذا مش غير
قانوني وبيحكوا انه دفع لها مصاري عشان
تضل ساكته برضو هذا مش غير قانوني هم ايش
بيحكوا بيحكوا المصاري اجت من المحامي
تبعه وهو رجع المصاري للمحامي تبعه بس
سجلها ان هذه تكاليف قانونيه طب شو معناته
تزوير برضه هذا مش كانوا مش غير قانوني شو
اللي بيحكوا طيب اي شركه انت بس بتدفع
ضرائب على المربح يوم ما بتدفع مصاري على
اللي بدخلك
بتقيم المصاريف من الداخل والباقي بتدفع
عليه ضرائب هم بيحكوا يوم انت حطيت يوم
انت دفعت المصاري هذه للمحامي تبعك
وكتبتها على الكتب ان هذه
مصاريف معناتها ما بتدفعوا عليها ضرائب
وهذه الاتهام يعني اتهام دقيق دقيق كتير
وبيخليه ينشك فيه الامر وانا شاكك فيه
بصراحه
هو اتهام يعني
حقيقي واتهام خطير يعني اتهام لمرشح رئاسي
باستخدام اموال الحمله الانتخابيه لدفع
يعني
دفعات شخصيه يعني بغض النظر عن القضيه
الجنسيه او غير الجنسيه هناك بالتاكيد
حاله اختلاس او او عدم مسؤوليه في استخدام
الاموال العامه يعني مثل ما تفضل قانوني
مش هذه النكته الغير قانونيه هو اخذ
الفلوس من من الحمله
واعتبرها اموال دفعه للمحامي وانا اعتقد
بغض النظر عن انه وين الفلوس راحت قضيه
انه الاموال كانت شخصيه هو تم دفعها
بطريقه غير قانونيه سحب من فلوس الحمله هو
اختراق قانوني بالنسبه لك مره اخرى انت
كمان رجل قانون يعني بالتاكيد تسمع العديد
من الامريكيين يقولون في الولايات المتحده
يمكن ان تنتهك القانون في السريه ولكن اذا
اكتشفت السلطات المعنيه بانك انتهت
القانون لابد ان تواجه العواقب يعني كيف
تختلف هذه الحاله حاله عن ذلك ما تختلف بس
هي اللي خلاهم يشكوا في المدعي العام اللي
في نيويورك انه من اول ما نزل عن الحكم
في المكتب في نيويورك وبرضو مكتب ثاني في
جورج وين المدعي عام اثنين سود كادو
يفتشوا على اي اشي
ممكن يفتحوا قضيه جنائيه ضده سرعات مش هيك
بصير مش بتروح بتفتش على كل شيء عشان
تلاقي اشي اذا شفتها في وجهك اه بتروح
بتعاقب ما هم فتش واي بني ادم اذا بتفتش
على تاريخه ممكن تلاقي اشي يعني اشغلته
هذا الشيء اللي الناس
على هذا الشخص وليش رحت تفتشوا على هذا
الرئيس وليش اثنين سود اللي بحاولوا
يروحوا يعني في ناس بيحكوا ان هذه عنصريه
ناس بيكرهوا البيض بيكرهوا رئيس ابيض
وراحوا بدهم يعاقبوه او او يعني قضيه انه
كان
قضيه انه الاشخاص كانوا من اصل افريقيا او
السود ما المفروض نركز عليها يعني
بالتاكيد ليس هناك يعني حقوق اقل لشخص في
مركز حكومي لانه اسود يعني انا شخصيا ادعم
كل القرارات اللي تم اتخاذها من
مسؤولين حكوميين سواء كان سوداء اذا كانوا
ملتزمين بالقرار الامريكي فما اعتقد قضيه
اسود وابيض لها علاقه في قضيه ترامب في
هذه الحاله
هيك الناس
لون بشرتهم اعتقد
كان سود او بيض بالتاكيد هناك يعني
تحقيقات تحصل بكل المسؤولين الامريكيين
انا ما عندي شك انه الرئيس السابق ترامب
انتهك القانون الامريكي 100 مره من خلال
يعني حمله الانتخابيه ويعني الفنادق اللي
يملكها فيعني قضيه انه تم تحقيق فيه هي
قضيه جانبيه القضيه الحقيقيه ان هو قام
باختراق القانون الامريكي وعلينا احنا
كمواطنين امريكيين انه ندعم اي
اجراءات يعني محاسب لو سمحتوا ماليه اريد
ان
اعطيكما استراحه
لاستماع لاقوال ضيف اخر ينضم الي الان
البروفيسور بنت جيرمان استاذ القانون
فيس بولايه نيويورك ينضم الي في هذه
الحلقه من مدينه
البريطانيه حيث يوجد حاليا
بالنسبه لالفين براك في هذه القضيه اولا
يعني ما حجم المغامره التي اقدم عليها
الفنبراج في هذه القضيه قضيه بتصورك
هذا سؤال بسيط للغايه لو ان ترامب ارتكبت
جرائم فيجب ان يحاسب كما هو يمكن ان يحاسب
لو انه
كان هناك
دعائعات غير صحيحه مزوره من شركه تامين
نحن لا نعرف حتى ماذا تكون التهم الجميع
يتحدثون عنها لكن بالضبط ما هي ما هي
التهم التي وجهها منذ عامه اذا دعونا
ننتظر ولكن اذا فعلا وجهت له ترى اتهامات
بالجريمه دعونا لا ننقذ ذلك في الشوارع
وسلام بل لنسمح للنظام القضائي الجزائي
باستمرار بالعمل كما اعمامون اي شخص اخر
دعوا المتعي العام
مفهوم مفهوم مفهوم انا اسالك الان عن
نعم مفهوم انا اسالك الان عن نفسه يعني
بالنظر الى تعقيدات هذه القضيه وبالنظر
الى الابعاد السياسيه التي قد تنظر اليها
القضيه من خلال تلك الابعاد السياسيه ما
حجم المغامره ان كنت تعتقد انها مغامره
التي اقدم عليها
بقبوله تعقب هذه القضيه
لما لا يقوم مدعي العام بمقابات قضيه اذا
وجد ادله على ان هناك شخصا ما ارتكبت
جريمه لماذا يمكن يكون ضد دونالد ترامب
مختلفا عن اي شخص اخر هو رئيس سابق ولا
تهمه لاي رئيس لكن اذا ظهرت ادله بانه كان
قدم رشوه لممثله الاباحيه هذه لكي لا تكشف
هذا الشان الخيانه التي قام بها
وقدم بيانات مزوره حول اموال الدفاعة لها
تبدو هذه المواد دفعها كانها اجور قانونيه
لتسهيل الامر على ترامب والابقاء على
اخفاء الامر عن الناخبين وعلى الارجح ايضا
لكي ينتخب فلماذا لا
لان ما تكون هذه جريمه
تدرس في المحكمه وتقرر هيئه المحلفين هل
هي كافيه لاثباتها ادانته لا افهم لاهل
لما تقول هذه ليست محكمه سياسيه اذا ارتكب
جريمه وكان هناك ادله على ذلك
مفهوم يعني ما حجم التحدي الذي تعتقد انت
ان الفين براج يواجهه مع كافن مكارثي
وبقيه الجمهوريين في الكونغرس
مثل هذا الامر سابقا
بالنسبه بالنسبه
لكارثي وجمهوريين اخرين هؤلاء يقولون انهم
يستندون الى ظهر الدستور الامريكي في
ملاحقه او في التحقيق فيما اذا كانت اموال
فيدراليه قد يستخدمها ابراج للتحقيق في
هذه القضيه هل هناك سند
دستوري لما يقوم به الجمهوريون مع ابراج
في الكونجرس بتصورك
دستور لا علاقه له بهذا الامر حاليا بل
السؤال هو هل ان حكم القانون في امريكا
سيعمل بطريقه عادله وغير منحازه بالنسبه
للجميع هذا هذا هو معرض لخطر حاليا اي حكم
القانون في امريكا ولن حكم القانون في
امريكا يمكن ان يعمل بشكل منصف نقطه انتهى
الامر
مفهوم يعني في الاجواء في الولايات
المتحده حاليا كما شاهدنا خلال السنوات
القليله الماضيه اجواء مشحونه سياسيا هناك
انقسام سياسي حاد شاهدنا في احداث اقتحام
الكونجرس نموذج لنماذج لعدم الاستقرار
الحاد في الولايات المتحده وبالتالي اريد
ان اسالك عن المعضله التي قد يواجهها محقق
من المحققين كابراج مثلا يعني هل يسعى
لتحقيق العداله كما يرى هو بصرف النظر عن
العواقب السياسيه التي قد تكون لذلك ان
تسببت في مزيد من عدم الاستقرار بين
والتشاحن والحرب على الاقل الكلاميه بين
الامريكيين
امريكا
مقسمه بشكل مؤلم هذا الوقت الحالي ترامب
خسر الانتخابات الاخير 2020 وادعى
رعاه ان يهاجموا على الكونغرس لمنع
الكونغرس من التصويت لصالح بايدن والان
يعتقد انه يعتقل يناشد رعائه لكي يطلقوا
يخرج الى الشوارع
ويخيفوا ويمنع المدعي العام من توجيه هذا
التوجيه التهاماته هذا هو ما يقوم به وهو
انه ذلك لا شخص اخر يقوم بذلك الديمقراطي
لا يقولون اي شيء فاذا فهذا هو الترامب
هذا الشخص
والمشاكل اذا دعونا نهدى هذا ما هذا فعل
ويقوم به ترامب هو يجعل البلاد اكثر
انقساما هو يسبب لنا
الالم والعنف
ولا اسمحوا لحصول هذا الشيء هذا امر لا
ينبغي ان يحصل اطلبوا الناس ان يهدؤوا ما
يحصل
شكرا
شكرا لكم
استاذ القانون في جامعه بيس انضم الي
مشكورا من مدينه
برلينغام البريطانيه حيث يوجد حاليا اعود
الى ضيفي الان كمال نعواش يعني هذه
المعادله بين تحقيق العداله دون ان تعرض
استقرار البلاد لمزيد من الهزات يعني
كيف تعتقد ان الفينبراج يواجه هذه
المعادله اسمع خليني انت حكيت نكته منيحه
يعني وانا بحكي لو لو
ترامب عمل الانشغالات مش دائما من صالح
البلد انك تعاقبه مش بس عشان رئيس انت
بتحكي على شخص في 70 مليون امريكي بيدعمه
70 مليون برجع بذكرك يوم يوم استقال من
الحكم اول اشي اجا عمل يوم صار رئيس اعطاه
عوفه كامل لانه عرف اذا حاولوا
يرفعوا قضيه جنائيه ضده انه بيجمع امريكا
بصير اختلافات في امريكا سواء انا بحكي
يعني مضبوط بتقدر تحكي القانون لازم يتنفذ
على الكل بس مش دائما احسن اشي هذا وخصوصي
عندك قضيه انا مقنع هي فيها سياسيه لو هو
عمل اشي غلط بس العقاب
مدعي مدينه مدينه هذه عمرها ما صارت عاده
السلطه في الدوله الفيدراليه
واللي بيحكوا عنه الهذا الحكومه
الفيدراليه شافت هذا الاشي قبل سنه وقررت
ما بدها تسوي اشي فيه انا بحكي انه غلط
هذا الشخص في هذه المعادله انت رائد
انه الجمهوريين عندهم حاله يعني دفاعيه
كثيره حاليا يعني بدلا من اخذ هذا الموقف
بانه يعني البحث عن اسباب لعدم
اتخاذ اجراءات قانونيه ضد رئيس
المعادلات المعقده انه والله هو ابيض
والمحاكم اسود احتمال يكون عنصري والله هو
يعني اول رئيس يتم حكم محليا طب انت خلينا
نشوف ايش الاجراءات القضائيه راح تحصل في
نيويورك ونشوف ايش المسار القضائي انما
بالنسبه
سامحني اريد العوده الى الموضوع يعني هل
تعتقد انت انه فعلا يواجه معضله بين اما
تحقيق العداله في قضيه
كما يرى هو او تقويض مزيد من تقويض الامن
والاستقرار في الولايات المتحده بلد منقسم
انقسام حاد سوى هذا مو شغله هو
موسياسي هو وظيفته انه يقوم
يعني البحث عن اختراقات للقانون وتنفيذ
القانون الامريكي اذا في حدا سياسي بده
يعطي عفو للرئيس ترامب اهلا وسهلا في يعني
اجراءات سياسيه ممكن انه تتدخل بالاجراءات
القضائيه بس ما ممكن نطلب من شخصيات
موجوده حاليا مسؤولين امريكيين في مسار
القضائي من انه يصير لهم
تحليل سياسي لقضايا قضائيه هذا هذا طلب
غير غير عادل من جهتنا يعني
منيح يعني اللي ممكن يصير من كل الاهتمام
اللي جاء للمدعي العام هذه انه اذا كان
عنده هدف سياسي انه هلا عشان كل عيون
امريكا عليه ممكن يفكر منيح وما يقدم
القضيه او ما يجيب القضيه الا اذا هو
متاكد مئه في الميه ان ان دارو ترانس غلط
لانه في خوف ثاني هلا من الديمقراطيين
بحكوا اذا انتم اتهمتوا ترامب
وفشلت الاتهام القضيه الجنائيه انتم
بتساعدوا ترامب انه يربح الرئاسه لان
الناس راح تشوفه مظلومه سواء في كثير
اشياء
سنعود لمساله للساحه الانتخابيه هذه
القضيه في الساحه الانتخابيه بين
الجمهورين والديمقراطيين انما انت كمحامي
مثلا نفترض فرضا انك بهذه المعادله عندك
شخص
في مثل الحاله بتاع
هناك انتهاك للقانون لنترك جانبا للجانب
الاخلاقي تاع
الانتهاك القانون طلب من شخص ان يدخل او
ان يسجل مبلغ
بتغطيه زائفه وانتهت القانون الانتخابي هل
تقبل ان تدافع عن هذا الشخص
انا كمحامي كمحامي انا علي اني احط
الحكومه في موقف انها تثبت كل اشي بتحكيه
سواء انا بقبل ليش لانه بشوفه فوق وفوق
هذا انا بشوف بالوقت الحاضر بغض النظر كل
اشي عمله غلط ترامب انه بهذه القضيه
بالضبط انه مظلوم وتدافع عنه بصرف النظر
عما قد يؤدي اليه ذلك من عدم الاستقرار
السياسي في البلاد تقول انا بشوف انك
بتتابع هذه القضيه راح يصير عدم عن
الاستقرار السياسي في البلد
وهذا اشي مهم يعني يوم انت في الاول حكيت
عن مقارثه وفي اخرى واحد اسمه
لازم احنا نحط في السجن
نسجن تبع المدعان هذا هلا بدا يسوي مشاكل
في جوا امريكا عشان هيك تاريخيا الامريكان
ما بيعاقبه الرئيس لانه بيعرفوا عدم
الاستقرار في جوا البلد على على ذكر ذلك
رائد جرار كما سبقت الاشاره عندما قال انه
سيعتقل يوم الثلاثاء الماضي طبعا لم يحصل
ذلك انما دعا عندما تحدث عن ذلك دعا
انصاره للاحتجاج يعني
بالنظر الى ما حصل ليس فقط في احداث
اقتحام الكونجرس ولكن مع من اقتحموا
الكونغرس قضائيا في وقت لاحق يعني ما حجم
المشكله الام التي تعتقد انها موجوده
حاليا في البلاد المشكله حقيقيه يعني نحن
راينا
التبعات
الخطاب الشعبوي من الرئيس ترامب عندما سال
او طلب من متابعيه ومناصريه الهجوم على
بنايه الكابتن يعني كان كانت قضيه كارثيه
للولايات المتحده فبالتاكيد هناك تخوف
حقيقي من تبعات دعوات الجديده
للتظاهر او الاعتصام اذا تمت اجراءات اذا
تم اتخاذ اي اجراءات قضائيه ضده في
نيويورك طيب عطا على ذلك اريد مره اخرى لو
سمحتم لي ان ارحب
برضه ماكدونالدز ضابط سابق في الخدمه
السريه الامريكيه ووحدات حمايه الرئيس
ونائب الرئيس والشخصيات الهامه في
الولايات المتحده قادمه كمشرف لعمليات في
اكاديميه الخدمه
السريه بولايه ماريلاند وهو محاضر حاليا
في قسم العداله الجنائيه في جامعه
نيوهيفندي ولايه
كناريل روبرت ماكدونا مرحبا بك في برنامج
من واشنطن ما حجم التهديد
للاستقرار الذي تواجه الولايات المتحده في
الوقت الراهن بسبب هذه القضيه قضيه دونالد
ترامبو في تقديرك
هذه هذه حادثه غير لا سابقه لها في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده احتمال اعتقال رئيس سابق
الكثير من الامور في هذا الموضوع في
القضيه والادانه او اتهامات المحتمله لان
هذا ان يظهر ان يقف رئيس سابق امام
المحكمه لجوء على الاتهامات كيف يمكن لهذا
الفرد الذي تحميه
مؤسسه فيدراليه كيف يعمل ويتعاون مع شرطه
نيويورك لكي يحصل على تقديم رئيس سابق الى
امام المحكمه بطريقه امنه وسالمه وكيف
يمكن ان يسمح لسكان نيويورك بالاحتجاج على
هذا الامر وهو ما سيحصل في كثير اقسام
الشرطه في نيويورك لحمايه العاملين في
المحكمه وايضا الذين يعيشون قرب هذه
المحكمه وبالتالي هناك امور كثيره نجهلها
لا نعرف سيحصل ذلك
ما الذي سيحصل ولك
اتصالات كبيره تجرح حاليا لجمعه خطه
لتحقيق ذلك بشكل جيد بدون اي مشاكل لجميع
الاطراف
وعطفا عليه يعني هل لك ان تصف لنا باختصار
حجم التحدي الذي تواجهه مختلف الوكالات
الامنيه في الولايات المتحده ليس فقط في
نيويورك في ظل انتظار ان يصدر قرار
في هذه القضيه
كما تعلمونهم من الواضح انه هو انه هو
المدعي عام الذي سيطر على كلائحه
الاتهامات المحتمله والامر وليس من الغريب
ان تاتي لائحه اتحامات الى مكان شعبي جدا
حيث يمكن تقديم اشخاص منشورين المحاكم
هناك امور كثيره لا نعرف وهذا هو جزء
المؤسف وايضا بعد اعلان لائحه الاتهامات
لسنه ونرى وذن هناك اجزاء كثيره في هذه
الاحجيه لا نعرفها وقد لا نعرفها الا ان
تتصل القضيه الى المحاكم وبالتالي هذا امر
لا سابق له لم نشده سابقا وعلى الارجح لن
نشهد ايضا غير السنوات القادمه فهذه حاله
فريده من نوعها هو مره اخرى السؤال هو ما
هي ماذا ستكون التهم ومكيفه تقدم وكيف
هناك كثير الاشياء المجهوله وهذا لا
يساعدنا على النفهمه هذه الاحجيه وبالتالي
علينا لاحقا ان نفهمها لاحقا اذا ما اعلنت
لائحه الاتهامات
ماكدونالدز كما تعرف يعني قبل احداث
السادس من يناير احداث اقتحام الكونجرس
كان هناك الكثير من التواصل بين انصار على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ثم حدثت احداث
السادس من يناير هناك
بطبيعه الحال تواصل حاليا مع انصاره انما
ما هو الدرس او ما هي الدروس التي تعتقد
انت ان
الوكالات الامن في الولايات المتحده قد
تعلمتها مما حصل في السادس من يناير لربما
تستفيد منها في الوقت الراهن في هذه
القضيه قضيه
هذا السؤال وجيه للغايه ان التحقيقات وهي
اعاده بناء لما حصل في السابق فمن يقوم
بهذا التحقيق بالتاكيد سيحاول اعاده بناء
حالات سابقه مشابهه واذ مره اخرى اقول
طبيعه هذا هذا المشكله هذه القضيه هو شخص
يحظى بحمايه من قبل وكاله لاخرى فاي ادله
لديه قدمها الى هيئه المحلفين الكبرى فهو
قد يقروا توجيه اتهامات ولكن تقرر الهيئه
المحلفين لا تقبل هذه اللائحه امور كثيره
هناك جانب جانب السياسي من الجانبين الذين
يثرون في سائل الاعلام يوميا هناك امور
كثيره تجري حاليا لكن المحققون المشاركون
في هذه القضيه يودون يعرفوا شيء واحد الا
وهي اين هي الحقيقه التحقيق سينجز في
نهايه المطاف لايجاد الحقيقه ما حصل هل
هذا سيؤدي الى احد اتهامات هل سيؤدي الى
اعتقاد هل سيؤدي لادانه كل هذا امر شيء
مخت تماما المهم الان هو معرفه ما الذي
حصل بالضبط فيما يتعلق بالتهامات التي
محتمله ان تقدم وكيف ستظهر هذه المعلومات
لصالح اما المدينه او لصالح المتهم اذا
هذا ما ينبغي ان ننتظر لنعرفه واذا كان
مذنبا فلابد ان يحاسب على تلك الجرائم كاي
شخص اخر
فالفقر لانه الشخص يحظى بحمايه من قبل
النظام الفيدرالي او لان رئيس سابق لا هذا
لا يعني لا يمكن
لا يجب على الاتهامات التي قد تعرض عليه
لاحقا ماكدونالدز شكرا جزيلا لك روبرت
سابق في الخدمه السريه الامريكيه ووحدات
حمايه الرئيس ونائب الرئيس والشخصيات
الهامه الاخرى في الولايات المتحده اعود
اليكما مره اخرى
رائد جرار
وكمال نعواش رائد بالنسبه الان للمشهد
للانتخابي في الولايات المتحده يعني هذه
القضيه
اين ترى ان الجمهوريين يمكن ان يستفيدوا
منها اين ترى ان ان قد تلحق الضرر بحظوظهم
الانتخابيه بحظوظ مرشحيهم الانتخابيين في
20 24
من الناحيه السياسيه سيقوم الحزبين
باستخدام القضيه لمصلحتهم يعني من الجهه
الديمقراطيه سيقوم الناخبين الديمقراطيين
او السياسيين الديمقراطيين بالتصوير
الرئيس ترامب والحزب الجمهوري
كرئيس يخترق القانون وله علاقات جنسيه وله
مشاكل قانونيه يعني من ناحيه اخرى
الجمهوريه سيقومون بتصوير الرئيس كضحيه
لنظام يعني يكره الرئيس ترامب بسبب مواقف
السياسيه يعني يسمونها
الولايه العامه
تحارب وفين سيقوم اللعب السياسي سيقوم
باستخدام هذه القضيه لمصلحتهم مهما كانت
النتائج بس علينا الانتظار
[موسيقى]
كان المدعي العام ديمقراطي او قانوني نحن
لا نتدخل ابدا انظروا الينا يعني مثال
لعدم التدخل فاعتقد
التهديد سيكون محدود على الحزب الديمقراطي
ولكن اذا بالحق بالحقيقه قاموا
بادانته سيكون هناك
اضرار اكثر على الحزب الجمهوري كمان معواش
كما قلت انت في السابق انه القضيه مسيسه
يعني هل يمكن ان يستفيد الجمهوريون من
التسيس انتخابيا ام ان التسييس يمكن ان
ينقلب عليه مش راح ينقلب عليهم وهذا انا
بامن فيه بغض النظر عن شو ما يصير مش راح
ينقلب عليهم بس
بتهيا انا ما رايحين يستفيدوا بغض النظر
يوم يوم داوم خسر الانتخابات الثانيه هو
مش بس عشان ديمقراطيين ما صوتوا له في فئه
من الجماعه الجمهوريين يصوتوا له اول مره
ما رضيوا يصوتوا له ثاني مره عشان اسلوبه
في الحياه
هدول اذا يعني ممكن ممكن اذا عملوا اتهموا
ترامب وقضيه جنائيه وساقطه القضيه
الجنائيه ممكن هذه الفئه تحكي والله هدول
بيركزوا على الناس اللي بفكروا زي
الجمهوريين اللي زي لازم ندعم ترامب انه
نفرجي نحنا واقفين مع بعض بس بيتهيا لي
انه ما راح يستفيد يعني
بطبيعه الحال قضيه
ليست هي
الخطر القضائي الوحيد الذي يتهدد
هناك قضايا اخرى ضده في جورجيا تتعلق
بالانتخابات في 2020 هناك قضيه مارالاكو
والوثائق السريه هناك احداث السادسه من
يناير بعد انتخابات 20 يعني كيف تعتقد ان
كل هذه المخاطر القضائيه مجتمعه قد اثرت
على وحده الحزب الجمهوري في دعم دون اسمع
من ناحيه الحزب ما اثرت عليه بس بجوز اثر
عليه هو اذا بتشوف يوم رشح حاله ثاني مره
مش بنفس
[موسيقى]
ما كسب نفس التشجيع يوم رشح حاله اول مره
يعني بشوف انه في كتير ناس زهقوا منه ومن
المشاكل اللي هو فيها شو ما بشوف انه انه
من ناحيه الحزب انه راح يضاعفهم بس هو
بجوز يضعف حاله
سريعا في اقل منه دقيقه ما رايك انت في
هذا الجانب رائد
القضيه الجنائيه القضيه القضائيه مختلفه
جدا عن القضيه السياسيه
القضيه القضائيه سيقوم باستثمارها
الجانبين لديهم يعني الخطاب السياسي
والتحليل السياسي لاستثمارها بس يعني
علينا مثل ما ذكرنا الانتظار حتى نشوف حتى
راح يكون في اي تحركات قضائيه حقيقيه في
نيويورك طيب
نواصل ما تبقى من هذه الحلقه من ساحه
الحريه هنا في العاصمه واشنطن في قضيه
كما سبقت الاشاره رؤساء امريكيون سابقون
اتهموا بالكذب وانتهاك القانون ولكن
الذي يواجه عده اتهامات قضائيه قد يصبح قد
يصبح اول رئيس سابق يدان جنائيه في ذكرى
غزو العراق العشرين عاد موضوع الغزو
ومسوغاته الى الواجهه بالتزامن مع قضيه
دونالد ترامب وستور ميدانييلز يشير الى ان
الرئيس جورج بوش الابن مثلا قد برر غزوه
للعراق بقضيه اسلحه الدمار الشامل التي لم
يعثر عليها في نهايه المطاف
من الجنود الامريكيين قتلوا واصيب اكثر من
30 الف منهم في حرب العراق وزير الدفاع
السابق دون درامز فيلد كان قد قال للجزيره
ان العالم اصبح افضل من دون صدام سالته هل
تكترث اسر عشرات الالاف من العراقيين
الابرياء الذين سقطوا خلال وبعد الغزو هل
تكترث لذلك
ولكن من جهه اخرى لديك مئات الالاف من
الناس قتلهم صدام حسين
والقى بهم في المقابر الجماعيه
الاشخاص العراقيون الذين قتلهم صدام حسين
بالسلاح الحمايه يعتقد اعتقد ان هؤلاء
يشاطرونني الشعوري
في العراق كان قد قال للجزيره هو ايضا انه
ارتكب اخطاء جسيمه هناك من بينها حل الجيش
العراقي سالته ان كان يقبل بانه يجب ان
يحاسب على ذلك وعلى دوره في الغزو
تمت محاسبه حزب جمهوري في انتخابات 2008
اذا كنت تريد اين وقعت محاسبه وعلى من
فعلا ان المسؤوليه في الديمقراطيه ان جزءا
منها انك تغسل الانتخابات هذا ما حصل لحزب
الجمهوري في 2009
ما رايك رائد جرار في هذا الربط بين
العراق
احنا نرحب
باتخاذ اجراءات قضائيه ضد الرئيس ترامب بس
بالتاكيد نطالب احنا كانريكيين
خصوصا من اصول عربيه وعراقيه وفلسطينيه
نطالب باتخاذ اجراءات قانونيه ضد رؤساء
امريكيين اخرين قتلوا الملايين من الناس
حول العالم ودمروا حياه الامريكيين هنا
فيعني قضيه المئه الف دولار و 120 الف
دولار نرحب
اتخادات القضائيه بس بالتاكيد يعني ان شاء
الله انه تكون هذه تفتح الابواب لاتخاذ
اجراءات قضائيه
20 ثانيه هل يفيد امريكا ان تفتح كل هذه
الملفات القديمه قضائيا الان لا لانه لانه
اذا امريكا اعترفت في اشي زي هيك او عاقبه
شخص زي جورج بوش او بريمر او شيء هيك
معناته بيحكوا للعراق انه انتم عندكم قضيه
ضد امريكا للتعويض سواء اميركا لو عارف ان
عاملين غلط مش راحت عاقبهم
شكرا جزيلا كمال العواش محامي معتمد لدى
المحكمه العليا الامريكيه وناشط جمهوري
شكرا كذلك لرائد جرار مسؤول العلاقات
الحكوميه في منظمه الديمقراطيه الان من
ساحه الحريه في وسط العاصمه واشنطن تحيه
لكم جميعا وشكرا لكل من شارك معنا في هذه
الحلقه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]